all this against the 23 year old
right-hander bryce wilson
yeah bryce wilson is uh pretty much the
gutsiest pitcher they have and what i
mean by that is nothing bothers him he's
kind of a bulldog that just gets after
it
probably believes he has the best stuff
in the league that's what you got to do
if you're a pitcher in this day and age
and anthony rizzo at the top it's a
stunt that's been done around here for a
long time to try to jump start the cubs
offense rizzo swings and sends a ball to
deep right field and anthony rizzo
that's caught at the wall oh man we all
thought he had it
and after all why wouldn't you think
that he's homer twice in five at bats
against wilson and i for one thought he
got him again
you can tell he was drifting enough
to where he thought he might have it and
then just did a little
jump there at the wall that's a good
feeling for starting pitcher so now
chris bryant wants a fly ball at the
lease to get the cubs on the board the
first and bryant lines it into the
opposite field one-nothing chicago see
that's a perfect example matt of why
when he hit her with his talent he'll
run into a bunch of homers when you hang
pitches but when a hitter like him can
stay on the ball and go to right field
you know the shifts on this is just good
hitting and this is what rossi was
talking about he likes the contact
and he had stretches of his team that
would go through contact but
unfortunately not enough has too many
swings and misses so now jason hayward a
run in runners at the corners with sugan
oh and wilson just blocked in a run
what in the wide wide world of sports is
it going on here he slipped
oh man that's a rough way to lose a run
two-nothing chicago
well he's gotta you know what you gotta
throw the ball and i know as he wishes
he had right there he got stuck with his
feet and if he just tosses the ball up
in the air he's fine
he tried to drop it but that's not a
[ __ ]
fourth start of the year for azelai and
happy that it's coming against somebody
else he has a bunch of experience
against the milwaukee brewers this year
and
out of the division now and
into some different competition at 5.40
era looking for his first decision of
the year
batting here with two gun in the base is
empty
chip shot ground ball
and ozuna is retired here come the cubs
with nobody out in the top of the third
inning baez again making his first
appearance of the series tonight
hamstring tightness having limited him
elevated pitch that he whacks into
center field chasing already that's
going to be more than enough to tag and
score
duffy bryant will advance to third
three-nothing chicago
he does a great and bad for bias even
though he didn't get it
yeah a very productive plate appearance
there for ross and the cubs and now
jason hayward
like that into the right field corner
four-nothing cubs
it's all about timing with his hands
with haywood
he's spread out away from the plate his
hands are there active with his hands
and he didn't get his tied up that time
his hands sometimes disappear when we
got the home
center center look from center field and
his hands stayed quieter and there
much better results
one out double first extra base hit for
atlanta tonight back to travis darno now
who takes the first pitch and hits a
shot to third for duffy
hitter on the screws but they got a man
there and there are two away now first
and second now with two away here's
austin reilly now who struck out on a
great slider back in the second and
riley's gonna make him pay this time a
base hit and a right for hayward the
five-time gold glover is up and throwing
wildly to the plate
albe scores and the braves are on the
board in the 40.
see that's a great approach by ryden
i guarantee you he went up there looking
to do this and he got a big two-out hit
after the two-strike hit batsman
and the braves as you mentioned
two out like all these is very fast and
he he got off the bag in really good
shape even a good throw by hayward
is not gonna get him trying to score
josh tomlin back to work in relief for
the atlanta braves as we get to the top
of the fifth inning fly ball the other
way
carrying still carrying and it's off the
wall
bae is on his way to third taking the
turn and heading
into third safely
now he could have had a slight chance of
an inside the park home run if what i
saw was correct when he hit it i think
he thought it was gone you're right he
doesn't he's not looking yet no he still
has it he knows it's getting going get
going get going
he didn't start running until he hit the
bag
so chances are it was still going to be
a triple but you never know
here's hayward now he has an rbi and a
stolen base tonight hayward has another
extra base here baez comes home and
scores and jason on his way to second in
and out five to one chicago lead
climate control you mean absolutely
they're guaranteed again
fly ball out there that all these can't
find the handle on throw to the plate
not in time hayward scores 6-1 chicago
well
this is a little unfortunate for the
braves they had to play
the infield in a position where
nobody could get to that ball turned
around look two guys racing with their
back towards the
catcher and hayward with good speed and
recognition of that ball not getting
caught
hayward we didn't get to see where he
was but i would venture he was halfway
down the line anticipating that ball
getting dropped advertising continuing
into the sixth inning and why not he has
been really good
tonight oh marcelo zuna got him is he
going to take a selfie at home
selfie maybe that's the start of
something he's hitting the buck 87 his
third homer of the year
it makes it a 6-2 ball game
maybe it's just one of those exhales for
marcelo zuna because he has not gotten
off to a very good start
and here's all you need to know about it
114 off the bat 479
feet now jake mariznick
nate jones has just given up the seventh
run of the game for chicago a solo shot
for jake mariznick it's 7-2 cubbies his
second of the year in his new uniform
lines the base hit into right field
it's going to score sogar
8-2 chicago
acuna has not had great returns since
injuring himself
against the cubs about a week and a half
ago on a sunday night there's a little
inside out swing and the base hit into
the opposite field
riley comes around to score
and it's an 8-3 chicago lead
and acuna sends a drive out to right
field that's going to wrap it up tonight
the cubs are able to survive tonight and
avoid the sweep snap the five-game
losing streak
and maybe restore a smile or two
[Applause]